- [DRock] I'll see
you in four hours.
- See you DailyVee.
See you in four hours.
(rap music)
Alright, I gotta
make this quick call.
(static)
(engine revving)
(silence)
- You know and the whole
place is obviously open--
- I just, I just
need to have a--
- float through.
- Two or three times a year
I want to do a real wine
event that matters,--
- Yeah.
- and this is the
place to do it.
Six weeks ago or so
I was in a meeting here
in LA and all the
gentleman I was with,
I was with Lindsay and
we were with David,
one of her mentors.
He said, "You guys have
a few minutes today?"
And we're like, "Well,
we can make it happen.
"What's going on?"
He's like, "You have come
and see this amazing place."
So we readjusted our schedules
in the middle of a kind of a
weekday drove down here and
were introduced to this amazing
gentleman that I'm excited to
introduce many of you
to but others know.
We did a little bit of a tour
that I know many of
you have already done before.
I was completely blown away.
Even more exciting to me is
as we were going through the
incredible wonderland that he's
created here in the middle of LA
I kinda looked at the
space we're in and I said,
"You know for a long time I've
been wanting to put together a
"wine dinner in LA and have a
mix of my friends and
acquaintances get together
and get to know each other."
So something that's been
bouncing around in my mind for
the last 18 months or so came
together when I saw this spot
and this incredible
energy that's created here.
So I'm having a lot of fun
watching you guys kind
of mix-and-match.
(light pop music)
Cheers.
Thank you.
Get home safe, love you all.
Cheers. Cheers.
Nice.
- Was fun.
- That was fun.
- [Blurred Man] Gary!
- [Gary] Hey bro.
- [Blurred Man] What up, dude?
- [Gary] Sorry, I'm late.
I think if you love process,
and you're comfortable
with adversity,
if you have the stomach for it,
and you love the journey
over the fruits and
riches of that journey
you now have the two
foundational pieces
to be a successful
entrepreneur.
You know, right now
entrepreneurship
is on this
interesting pedestal.
All of you want to be one.
Everyone wants to be one.
But the truth is, it sucks.
It's hard.
Almost everybody loses.
Almost everybody loses
and that is not something we're
having a conversation around.
You genuinely have
to like getting beat up.
You generally have
to like the conflict.
You generally have to have an
enormous amount of patience
to really actually pull it off.
In a world where everybody now
gets to play in social media,
you create a profile,
you're in the game.
In a world where
everybody gets an at-bat,
we're about to realize that
the far majority of
people aren't good enough.
You know we haven't had to
quantify this before because
there were people
in place to filter people
that America got to see
and most of them were
qualified to some level and
so all we ever saw in
the news and the media
was a curated .0001% of us and
of that 90% weren't good enough
because the human that
decided that was flawed.
Now what we have
is an ecosystem
where everybody's getting out
there and saying they're great.
The problem is far majority
aren't going to be great
at what they pontificate
at being great at
and we're gonna watch them
fail in front of our eyes.
(light R&amp;B music)